[Applaudissements]
bonjour madame montrouge où paraît-il
que vous avez des problèmes avec ça je
m'en vais regarder votre antenne madame
rousseau
oui
je vais vous montrer c'est quoi l'amour
voilà bon sens
ah oui
[Musique]
le
voilà vous êtes sur une île déserte vous
devez en embrasser un ce serait qui sur
la bouche alors y'en a que car je
trouvais je les dis déjà je trouve que
de leur dire c'est quand même pénible
qui vont se moquer mois pujadas je
trouve un certain charme et n'est pas
dans votre truc c'est vrai que j'aime
bien le grand concours des chroniqueurs
je suis l'animateur de bâtard je vais
vous poser votre ex que bien sûr bande
de bâtards genevoise est question à
chacun d'eux
carole rousseau votre question le mot
parisien et à aspirine ce que le mot mer
et à aimer mairie marc et ramé attendez
attendez ont déjà testé le monde
oui c'est bien oui mais c'est pas grave
bref jouer qu'un rôle à la réponse est
non mais ils se sont trompés ici en paix
domp et sears et aimer la bonne adresse
était bien pas bien joué bah ouais ouais
mais c'est la régie locale excusez-nous